oh but you know what's so funny I was
like bouncing level but I had to do this
yeah it looks like you're wearing clown
shoes
are those Papa shoes
oh hey Mia place
me a place place
Mia place yes
this is what we do every day
for breakfast and dinner for Mia what
baby
get it break it with the conscious that
your papa was break it down break it
down
she broke his shoe
the strap you see it
what are we gonna tell Papa
that Mia broke it are we gonna tell him
okay
oh
yeah you gotta buy new ones
oh wait a minute Mia Place nope place
don't be funny place
Mia so yes taika
oh the monkey on the floor
well how did she get it that means
someone didn't put it away
hey go give her food though monks
oh
why'd you do that
well it's actually not her fault because
she took off her his goggles his mask
was not her fault because she can't tell
if they're her toys or or yours
okay so part of place Mia place
yes part of her obedience training she's
supposed to stay in place and this is
place when she's calm
she's laying down
so I put her in place mainly to eat
because she gets crazy and tiger doesn't
like it
shouldn't I knew I shouldn't have turned
the camera by myself but I did it anyway
um yeah so
place place place no place yes
yeah that's part of her opinions
training
that's a lot of work it's a lot of
Maintenance work obviously it's a lot of
work to train them to do it but it's a
lot of Maintenance I have to do it every
single day and the days that I don't I
can immediately see a decline but as
soon as I put e-color on those are the
prongs that give like a slight little
slight little buzz
um Shades a little bit better
right now we're doing
good and it's been super cute because
that's Tiger's responsibility he feeds
her and
um every morning and dinner he doesn't
complain once
and it's been awesome because it gives
them responsibility check out the whole
thing happened oh Jesus
I think my dude's sick leave it no
do
I like the ball no no do I like to Vlog
yeah yeah it's really cool I get to I
get to have all my memories in one space
[Music]
what are you touching
oh your thigh your inner thigh okay
[Music]
when you were two years old used to be
so funny you're still funny you're very
funny even now
look at you I want to laugh already
see hilarious
[Music]
you're hilarious
yeah
no no no no no too many commands too
many commands you lost her should we
don't do that
you see
you lost her you're supposed to just say
okay that's what we do every day what is
going on
hey so today you do homework right no
why this is the weekend
I know she's horrible I can't believe
she did that to Papa's shoe
probably she's so angry to me is Papa
doesn't get does he get angry
he does that I've never seen him do that
that's more like Mama Mama does that
okay
foreign
and there's a lot of poop so right now
we're at Lorenzi Park and the reason why
I wanted to come here I thought I saw a
body of water and I'm like what kind of
Park
is not fun that contains a body of water
because there's gonna be Birds we want
to see birds we know what birds look
like but we want to see birds then we
want to see birds
no okay I want to see birds so we're
here to see birds and then silent Mike
gave taika his Tonka truck when he was
taika's age look at that
crazy bones and tiger product because he
really wants to play with it huh monks
all right Duty let's go
that's gonna be heavy you got it all
right let's go
you're too buff
yeah all right dude
so the tiger wasn't kidding he really
didn't want to see the birds we're here
and he's playing
he's somewhere in there this thing is
massive
taika
where are you oh there you are
there he is this thing is huge huh dude
and he's not playing with his truck I'm
watching his truck and this fur baby
all right so not even five minutes into
playing taika says he has to use the
restroom so we were once over there
now we're all over here because of the
yes
panties or pennies
like underwear or money
oh do not touch it did you flush the
toilet I didn't hear it
use your foot look it's up there it's on
top that don't use your foot
don't touch it
monkey don't do that let's go but anyway
right out here are the birds look at all
the birds monkey
yeah but they're still birds come here
Tykes
so monkey before we go play
we have to look at these ducks okay
look at these guys
that guy's cool look at that one he's
like chocolate chip he's like cookies
and cream
you see him
this one wow that one's pretty
yeah yeah but they're gonna go inside
the water because they're scared
[Applause]
well look at all those look like they're
about to land in the water
wow wow
I think you're scaring them dude
they'll fight back okay
they do
have you ever been bitten by a duck it
hurts
you have been bit by a duck
okay monkey you got an idea what are you
doing
you're fishing can I see what you're
using to fish
oh can I see it okay
got it and then what do you want to do
you want to get what kind of fish
any kind got it
wow you're popular all the birds are
hoping that you give them some food
no you're not gonna smack anybody
oh Maybe
okay now we're at taika's dream come
true
wait where are you
I see you
look at your hair standing up because of
aesthetic
hey that's not the way to use it
that's not the way to use it
Spiderman
taika the Spiderman
me I'm not even touching you how am I
gonna make you fall off
sure
don't fall don't fall
good job
so we are back home monkey did you know
that you played for an hour dude
yeah you had a really good time and
because of that now it's lunchtime then
it's nap time but for lunch what did you
want dude
and you know I gotta get my ham and
pineapple and bro
oh and tiger got his pepperoni
yes pineapple ham they belong together
if you don't think they do you're
tripping you are tripping okay let's eat
okay okay okay
hello
so I told myself that when tiger took a
nap I would start cleaning and
organizing and mind you it's a Saturday
all right you know that thing they say
about drunk people and kids being the
most honest
case in point yes so today is a Saturday
I was gonna get all up in it you know do
my damn thing and then when Tycho went
to sleep I said
not today Satan and I took a nap too
you don't even know what I just said
what did I say you see a little
organized I know that's what I said I
didn't organize today I took a day off
[Music]
okay so I told him that when he went to
sleep he needed to sleep in his own bed
because I'm gonna be cleaning my my room
but then I laid on the couch and bra
this couch is like so comfy you know
what I'm saying
yeah you're fine okay I'm fired in other
news both taika and I geez
took a nap we feel good I didn't feel
like Mia took a nap Mia did you take a
nap may I come did you take a nap Mia
Mia
ticket
did you take a nap yeah did you take a
nap did that yet oh she did okay so she
took a nap now we're awake about to have
dinner she was like sleeping right now
oh but right now taika's getting
creative and what are you doing Monkey
drawing on your old table cool what are
you gonna try to draw
I don't know you don't know yet you're
just gonna go with the flow
okay
okay I want to interrupt you but we'll
I'll check in with you later okay to see
where you're at it's okay
you're gonna jump on the couch man you
got a busy day today
okay those fumes are pretty gnarly so
don't get too loopy okay don't smell the
fumes too much
I love you you smell that smell from the
marker
yeah that's the fume
it sometimes it gives my mom gives your
mama a headache just careful okay
okay
oh no it's getting loopy
how's your weekend going Mia
is it good
no no I'm trying to record you don't
give me don't give me hugs and kisses
don't give me
yeah
ah do you think you're gonna give her
food hey let's try about my sweater
stop that so hey come back come back Mia
oh would you like my castle what I did
yeah it looks really cool hey
Mia come Mia come can I talk to you no
so he said no she said please
go away wait I want to interview you so
you've let hey come back come back
so you've been living here hey so you've
been living here for about a month now
right yeah
don't you draw on her hey so you've been
living here for a month right maybe two
months
how do you like it do you like it
do you like it is it fun here
is it fun Mama yeah I got I got two toys
I like it hey hey hey come back come
back so do you like living here
oh my God
what she wants me to leave her alone she
just went outside
excuse me ma'am I was talking to you
you're so rude
okay right there
hey she's back hey so can I ask you some
questions now
okay
yeah
so one of my favorite Asian desserts are
these Sesame rice balls if you've never
had them
you are missing out I don't particularly
know much about the the brands obviously
because I can't read Chinese however
anytime I see
Sesame rice ball I am going to buy it so
this is what it looks like they're like
these little Frozen balls
okay one-handed operation please
[Applause]
so they're like this clearly I've eaten
oh my God there's only two left
okay
there it goes
Frozen little balls you boil some water
[Applause]
you let them boil for a bit once they
start floating clear light and put
enough water in there but once it
appears like they're floating maybe
within the next five minutes
um you pull them out and they're ready
to eat and then I'll show you what it
looks like on the inside
okay so I don't know how long it's been
but I'm gonna assume it's been like
three to five minutes water is boiling
like a mo fog so you get your Asian
spoon if you don't have it don't worry
about it I'm just extra as and I
live with an Asian man
oh you know what I think
these might still be
a bit Frozen but I don't know because
my Dumas
didn't add enough water okay well we'll
figure it out together
usually you want to keep it for at least
like three to five minutes
okay
let out
and I like drinking some of the water
what happened Tykes
so I'll do that
she was trying to use your stuff let it
sit there because as you can imagine
they are super damn hot so I'll let it
sit there kind of cool off a little bit
okay
so it's still hot as hell you see that
but I gotta show you what's on the
inside
so we're gonna make it work here we go
I'm gonna bite
half and you want to keep it on the
spoon because it's going to start oozing
out all this sweet yummy think of it
like um the outside like mochi-ish
um but not as like chewy as Mochi but
similar Fashion on the inside
it has like Roundup Sesame with like
something sweet so I don't know if it's
like a sugar a simple syrup or a honey
come that was kind of nasty but
uh
this is
so bomb
look at that
mm-hmm
a little bit of the water
so good
hmm
it's not too sweet that's what I like
about it I could easily eat this size
like maybe three
after three
I'm like that's way too much sweet
so good highly recommend it okay
my last and final one
where did you done
so good
you don't want to put it back in the
water because if you do
all the inside is just going to come
back out
and then you're looking to join because
it's just in the water
um
Asian restaurant
and they have black sesame
balls in the dessert section
must try right meow
okay so taika wanted me to interview him
about his table creation are you ready
taika okay show me your table creation
and tell me what what are we looking at
here
you can put them here you put them in
there
okay
yep okay what do you want to tell me
[Music]
she just wants to smell she's not gonna
do anything
tomorrow okay but what's the story you
were telling me about a castle and some
lava
like the look of Castle
uh-huh
them up
if the person in there and I'm like
there oh we'd like it
yeah do we like it no yeah
she went yeah yeah yes yes she looks
easy so now you're gonna draw this guy
okay cool can't wait to see what you
create look at her you like watching
tiger yeah but
yeah
oh she loves you she wants to play with
you so bad
okay okay
oh oh you're gonna get her riled up
[Music]
oh
are you okay
did she push you that hard
oh she's beating you up she goes do you
want some of me punk
calm down are you watching for me you
want some of me punk huh you want
something you are somebody huh
oh my God
oh what a cheater she went outside
she don't want this smoke she don't want
no smoke she left
hey you want some smoke hey you want
some smoke
you want something with this
you buy some of that oh you're kicking
it back you want some of this
laughs
you want something
she wants all the
okay I think you're scaring her with the
chair
I think she's really scared
oh sugar water oh she's getting charged
up she's getting hydrated
you want some of these
no I think she's scared at this point
let's see let her come back in no no let
her come back in oh okay she knows
you're about to party
she left
oh she back she back she back
[Laughter]
no put it down
put it down she's really scared of it
but she's not she's scared
oh she back
why is she scared no she's not scared
anymore she's playing with you let's see
if she comes back oh she's back she's
back
[Laughter]
bro what
yeah she's drinking water
I'm gonna draw on the glass yeah right
it's your move Mia
it's your move Mia what do you want to
do huh
it's your move Mia
what do you want to do
she doesn't want any of this action
oh
foreign
close the door young man
okay just had leftover pizza for dinner
was that amazing or what no
yes
how my life has been
this past year I'm in the middle of
measuring for a runner
and I never finished the job I think I
got my version of ADD
and I just left it here it's been like
this for maybe an hour now so we will
finish tomorrow
and like home decor stuff and kind of
like all the stuff I'm about to start
getting for Layer Two of our home is
that something that's interesting to you
guys so let me just I'll continue more
of this in tomorrow's Vlog but yeah
hit me with some questions I'll give you
more of like a
an interior design tour tomorrow of just
like the first pass of everything that I
got uh so far
oh my God
I never really got to put this guy to
bed okay
on that note
peace good night see you tomorrow